participants in everything from fantasy
football and March Madness pools to big
dollar wagering on games and matches are
rejoicing tonight the US Supreme Court
has ruled a federal law banning sports
gambling in most states is illegal my
colleague an anchor of Fox News ignite
shannon bream is here to tell us what
that means
today's six to three opinion from the US
Supreme Court is set to up and the world
of sports gambling in an historic way
the justices struck down a federal law
blocking States from sponsoring
operating advertising promoting
licensing or authorizing sports gambling
in most all situations but they really
said was that Congress doesn't have the
right to tell state legislators what to
do that that should be up to the
legislators and the voters Justice Alito
who authored the majority opinion
likened the law to posting federal
officers in state legislative chambers
armed with the authority to stop
lawmakers from voting quote a more
direct affront to state sovereignty is
not easy to imagine Justice Ginsburg
writing the dissent argued the court
could have used two restraints in
nullifying the federal law rather than
quote deploy a wrecking ball adding when
a statute reveals a constitutional flaw
the court ordinarily engages in a
salvage rather than a demolition
operation how today's decision plays out
will differ across the country states
like New Jersey Delaware West Virginia
and Mississippi are expected to move
quickly with a legislative framework
already in place at the state level
Gaming analysts expect as many as 32
states to offer legal betting within the
next five years there is a federal law
in place that appears to ban gambling
across state lines meaning states that
do move forward with legalized gambling
will have to tackle the issue of
policing their own cyber borders with
today's opinion so clearly backing
states rights some expect other
controversial issues could soon be ripe
for the picking this could impact some
anything from marijuana gun lols really
what the court affirmed was Congress
cannot commandeer the states well we are
still awaiting decisions in several
high-profile cases including disputes
over religious
Burtie forced Union fees gerrymandering
and of course travel ban 3.0 they're all
do between now and the end of June Brett
all right Shannon thank you